La boule de fort ressemble un mélange entre la
pétanque et le bowling. Le but est de s'approcher
le plus possible du cochonnet appelé ici "le
maître" ou "le petit". La subtilité du jeu
repose sur le déséquilibre de la boule : elle
possède un côté plus lourd que l'autre d'où son
nom de boule de fort. Toute la difficulté réside
dans l'habilité à maîtriser cette trajectoire.
Quand la boule va quitter la main, c'est en fin
de compte souvent le majeur, s'il est dans l'axe
de la boule on aura une trajectoire qu'on aura
définie. Si jamais on déplace le majeur la boule
va commencer à tanguer et la trajectoire va être
faussée. Donc l'idéal c'est d'avoir les trois
doigts qui sont joints avec le majeur au milieu.
En fin de course la boule va pencher vers son côté
fort et donc changer de direction. Il existe un
autre paramètre pour pimenter les parties : c'est
utiliser les rebords surélevés de la piste.
Selon la légende des mariniers de la Loire aurait
inventé ce jeu dans le fond des gabarres. D'autres
assurent que ce sont les prisonniers espagnols
qu'ils auraient pratiqué dans des fossés. Ce
jeu traditionnel est un éloge de la lenteur. Une
partie peut durer plus d'une heure. C'est amusant
et puis il y a la convivialité entre compétiteurs,
il n'y a pas de rivalité, c'est bon enfant, on
s'amuse, on rigole, on se chambre un petit peu,
c'est ce qui donne l'attrait de ce jeu. C'est
très très reposant j'aillais dire. Pour sûr,
ce jeu est une distraction ligérienne recensé
depuis le 17e siècle entre Saint-Nazaire et
Blois. La boule de fort est officiellement
reconnue comme patrimoine immatériel du
Pays de la Loire. Sur les 350 clubs existants,
l'écrasante majorité se situe dans le Maine et
Loire. La Touraine quant à elle compte
une quarantaine de sociétés. Ces clubs
sont souvent exclusivement masculins mais la
pratique est ouverte à tous les visiteurs.